hot breath and this comes from mitt wolf
he says uh when nate bargatsi was on
here he talked about how comics need to
get back to murdering
and he would he was like murder he would
like say it like from his soul he was so
intent about murdering on stage but uh
so he says when was the first time you
murdered
and what made the difference
uh thank you for the question um
i can't really remember the first time i
murdered
but i did feel comfortable on stage
pretty early on because i had done a lot
of acting in
high school and college so being on
stage was not
foreign to me at all but it did take a
little time to kind of
get my footing in terms of stand up um
but i do remember
like killing maybe in the first
you know few years where i kind of felt
like oh you know i think i'm on to
something here and i
i have a style and yeah i mean that's
it's a great feeling um but you know i'm
sure
nate probably alluded to this there's
different types of uh murdering or
killing like there's
if you're doing it like in a way that
feels cheap to you
uh and as a young comic that that can be
the danger
if you have something that kills but
maybe it's
um you know maybe it's cheap in in
whatever way
uh you know and that's that's kind of a
little bit of a trap that young
comedians
tend to fall into uh because when it
when as he said you know when you kill
it feels
it feels so good um but you know it has
to square with
uh your integrity too you know and that
varies from person to person
uh so you'll know if you're killing with
a cheap laugh or something that doesn't
really square with your integrity
versus if you kill with something that
you know is is com coming from your
voice and as
authentic that's that's the best feeling
because then you don't have any
qualms about it